chose de toi un an
mais pas tu t'appelles comment des gens
d'après françois parce que c'était
mitterrand et valéry giscard d'estaing
venant ici je suis un peu un peu
mystique moi et je crois beaucoup en
voyant tous ces trucs là et c'est une
voyante qui va donner selon la bouger
les tables ouais ouais ça a marché dit
non tu t'appelles comment ou jean louis
jean louis coujault voilà bon ton surnom
maintenant il fera sûrement comment tu
t'appelles
ils veulent leur intimité françois à
bonds pourraient pas mon gros plus ça
bien pu signer en bb à b ça c'est gentil
alors anthropologie rapidement comme est
une mesure jamais sans doute est ce
qu'on fait à la gym et gris jeu près 68
kg je me dis qu'il est dans ça va ça va
bon alors les cheveux je n'ai pas blanc
si je suis blanc mais je fais des
petites mais je n'ai pas besoin des
colleurs était sur un bras c'est la
vraie couleur de cheveux
les us ont marre on sait les signes
particuliers opérations non brouage non
cicatrices j'en ai une dans la tête j'ai
pris un coup monté sur la tête un jour
oui en quoi on ne bat ans
j'ai une cicatrice la whey un coup de
couteau la maladie chronique allergies
non tu feras des implants quand tu sois
plus âgé des listings trucs comme ça
pourquoi pas je sais pourquoi non
pourquoi pas pourquoi pas je ne dira pas
voulu dire à ceux catherine morel le
deal lutèce et guerre d'algérie ça je
savais pas tenir ou en algérie à oran
c'est vrai qu'ils parlent espagnol
partie des tout petits ma mère nous
parle espagnol par l'institut espagnol
parce qu'il est sain en algérie avait
évoqué colonie espagnole et bâton du
côté d'alger signés
alors un jour c'est à csl à chaque fois
qu elle seule de ces dure un jour on m'a
dit faut y aller pour partir c'est en 60
ou également 1,62 moi j'y crois parce
que moi j'ai connu si tu veux vraiment
le départ d'algérie jeté mon j'avais 8
ans ouais mais j'ai connu si tu veux
vraiment le stéréotype de la du
débardage jerry c'est à dire est que
maher soeur d'arriver en france les
valoches et où j'ai vraiment connu ça et
si tu le vends sur le coup je réalisais
pas chez réaliser plus tard sur son
twitter j'ai pu le faire
ce qui s'est cassé dès l'âge de 4 ans
c'est un truc qui m'a marqué après kim
amap qui a pris surtout quand j'y suis
retourné j'ai chanté j'ai championne
avec ma mère j'ai chanté à alger deux
soirs et quand j'ai fait une chanson qui
s'appelle laurence 1062 les musiciens
avaient un peu peur où il y avait 4000
arables pendant deux soirs qui était
froide saeki qui s'approprie et un petit
peu français
quels sont tes rapports aujourd'hui avec
les arabes parce que finalement on
pourrait dire que le fait que les arabes
en justifie répète avec les b france en
algérie
moi je m'entends vachement des avants et
c'est moi je n'ai pas souvenance de
du racisme je suis connue on a connu la
laci moi j'ai connu le racisme parce que
quand j'arrive je me souviens quand je
suis venu d'algérie à l'âge de 10 ans je
me souvenais on me disait beaucoup salle
pieds noirs qui m'a compris il s'agit
comme tu l'a connu ici en arrivant ouais
alors tu as dit aussi j'ai une certaine
culture j'ai rien de neuf à bec on prend
toujours pour un analphabète géant
rhénan c'est vrai qu'on a tendance à
prendre les chanteurs dit populaire pour
des cons je suppose missionnement qu'on
transporte la source de la loire par
exemple c ou c'est non mais c'est pas il
sert pour moi c'est un critère depuis
quatre ans 15 tu connais ouais quand
même ouais ouais
la source de la loire tués chaque année
les comprends qu'ils aient tellement
j'ai enfin des gens si jamais été très
fort pour elle quand tu fais de la
musique de film si ça les gens le savent
que moi et il ya d'ailleurs jamais
kenneth johnson qui a dit nous en
amérique on à quincy jones a en france
vous avez en france vous avez en soi
mais les risques en mer du nord
à mon avis elle a déconné doit être un
peu amoureuse est amoureuse de toi
non mais dans la vie à la fif koné mai
son plein on parle de musique de film et
c'est là l'unique centre non ça fait un
triomphe et te dire pourquoi
ouais parce que ce qui vaut au samedi
savez vous connaissez pas très bien la
route de cette pop star comme moi je
voyais double y rendez vous c'était un
mélange pour moi de tina turner de de
streisand et lui savait pas trop tu te
droguer
jamais jamais un jour on m'a fait que
maps et à yadi rsa ouais c'était bruce
springsteen sur scène la voie à la
naissance en italie mais c'est pas mon
truc
ouais aux gars étaient là ça fait
tourner la tête sarouel et on n'a pas
non c'est pas montré je préfère boire
deux trois verres de whisky sarthois
ouais alors l'amour maintenant à pacy
témoin une femme remarquable c'est vrai
à vous êtes rencontrés comment avec
michael je te raconte pas tu peux comme
ça il se sera pas d'eux ici paris un
jour il y avait c'était un anniversaire
d'un copain manquait un restaurant un
qui s'appelle le gorille et puis ça
m'emmerdait d'y aller alors il y adeux
ni mon attachée de presse et amie
surtout tu ça m'emmerde une discussion
tu peux pas faire ça c'est un mec simple
wiki à windy qui a été remis à nicole
calfan à des schémas faire bouger alors
j'y lis je viens mais tu me la paume
hathaway
et si tu à [ __ ] de sa part parce que
veut dire qu'on cesse comme ça
franchement quand on voit dans paris
match c'est vrai à une comédie française
moi je chante
populaire
et jeudi une phrase on s'emmerdait un
peu j'ai dit on serait tellement bien
en
mais elle t'a dit pourquoi pas ouais
c'est charmant 10e pole ici paris la cci
biotech rose donc c'est donc c'est un
peu elle quitta je veux dire là c'est
dragueur toi j'aime beaucoup les femmes
les jeunes filles ça c'est l'art gratuit
l'arc vtt tu te fais là si je te dis que
j'ai connus qu'en principe ce jeu là qui
va me prendre pour un prétentieux dans
mais c'est vrai mais en principe ça se
passe comme ça que ses pieds noirs tout
simplement non cotées sont aussi des
jaloux je suis partial betteraves en
rigole t elle à la maison mais tu sais
moi j'ai une femme à part moi j'ai une
femme et ma soeur mathieu lailler pour
des pudiques aux mecs vous balader à
bois la maison
oui je me balade à paul parce qu'il ya
des gens afin de vendre petit non pas
devant le petit il est si quand je
prends mon bail gamme voire mai
je peux pas me balader à poil pascal à
bonn planeur ce faux pas pour dernière
qu'elle savait comment rester là avec le
physique que tu as est ce que tu as déjà
eu des spas des tentations homosexuels
des expériences homosexuelles et que
dire un truc voilà grâce à youtube
je vais te dire un truc j'ai un
collaborateur qui homosexuels
complètement mais qu'ils veulent et
hisser mon pauvre en sera-t-il a toutes
les qualités sont celles là